most of the top chess players are in
fact and uh
i actually recall an interview with
magnus carlsen and he was saying that
you know if he's not in competition with
other people he's in competition with
himself and okay okay i'm going to get
really excited here because my favorite
opening is on the board it is called the
caracan and uh thank you thank you for
being here
and uh if we have a rewind to last
month's charity cup final between these
two the karo khan actually made quite a
big impression there both players played
the karakan as black and uh it's not
necessarily part of their normal
repertoire magnus only delves into the
karakan occasionally but
when he does it tends to be with some
ideas behind it remember magnus
carlsen's 125 game unbeaten streaking
classical chess that was ended by duda
and magnus played the kara khan in that
game oh that he ended up losing so
not great memories necessarily for
magnus carlsen in the carragher against
duda and meanwhile the two nights
variation as we call it because white
brings two knights to the center and now
the move that ivanka suggests in her
book as i recall bring the bishop out
and nowadays there are other ways for
black to play but this bishop move
for a solid one it's not just me
actually uh erwin lami in his chessable
course also recommends this
yeah i've always been reluctant to play
this move as black i've played it a few
times in my life in my life but
you love the way the bishop yeah you
love the bishops
magnus loves the bishops as well doesn't
he generally i mean he much prefers
having the bishop here
so yeah so magnus has parted with the
bishop he's traded off his slight square
bishop for a night so that's a fair
trade but note how magnus has put all of
his central points on light squares here
we're just about to see another trade uh
of pieces but yeah black's central pawns
at least drawn light squares to try and
make up for the fact that he lacks a
light-squared bishop
and uh yeah i don't think it's anything
too serious necessarily to worry about
white has an advantage here for short
because he has the bishop pair and
black's knight will struggle to compete
against that light squad bishop long
term
but uh duda pausing meanwhile is he just
going to recapture this point maybe the
second bring his queen across to another
squad yeah yeah well it looks a bit
silly actually i was thinking the queen
goes to dart square to hit
hit g7 uh stopping black from developing
but
i am bit surprised the evaluation bar
has gone so so mental there because it
doesn't look like there's anything big
in this position
um how can they be um like he's done
nothing wrong so far no black hasn't
well it's not the most uh common
response actually to relinquish the
tension in the center so early normally
black kind of develops knights and kind
of leaves the position a little bit more
tense and here i mean there's black's
position is very very solid but uh one
kind of downside i see with black is
that uh when you think about the long
term when you think 10 moves down the
line it's only really white who is
actually going to expand with the pawns
kind of has the kind of straightforward
plan
and
i i have to say as much as i love the
kara khan
not necessarily a fan of the way that
magnus has played it is a little bit too
defensive for my liking and uh queen
takes porn on the board and now magnus
offering a trade of queens which i i
think is very um instructive actually
yep it's very sensible here to trade off
the queens however bishop pez they do
gain a lot of power in the end game as
well the more pieces disappear the more
influence bishops have and we talk about
the bishop a lot white's dark square
bishop doesn't look too impressive right
now but it will eventually get into the
game white has ideas of pushing pawns
maybe on the left side of the board i
remember a really instructive win by
nigel short in english grand master he
actually in a very similar position to
this he just moved the white rook in the
corner across one square and started
pushing the white b pawn forward uh just
to undermine
um just to undermine black's pawns on
that left flank
and uh he's definitely listening to
music
he's maybe played the least ambitious uh
carrot card i've ever seen but he's
enjoying it
and uh okay just pushing a pawn forward
there and look this is a very magnus
type of move pushing his pawns forward
to stop the idea i mentioned of white's
pawns marching forward on the left side
of the water gaining space with response
and uh can i share with you some selfies
uh because aovox
says that this is the best start to the
weekend and they've finally got their
hands on
my book on the karakan
and uh now yeah you can get it signed
well you just have to
yeah we'll find a way we will find a way
and i've got my coffee side javanco i
remember oh do you did i sign you up you
did you said to my favorite grandmaster
oh sorry simon
truth comes out
[Laughter]
can i be your favorite gingerground
master you can
and whilst the players are kind of
developing their pieces we also have a
tweet from john fredericktop who is
watching the show from paraguay and also
cheering for magnus carlsen and
again vignesh is watching the show from
hyderabad and uh he he says that their
sons aj and eshen
are glued to the match
uh prague was playing so yeah it's so
great to see where everyone is watching
the show from and uh just everyone
enjoying the fun and uh there the
players are playing some moves very
quickly and magnus improving dark
squared bishop not taking the music
anymore he's looking a little bit more
focused looking very serious and i think
he's just confused about what dude has
done and to be honest i hate what dude
has just done on the last couple of
years because he has just completely
given away the dark squares look at that
black dark square bishop it controls
anywhere the white rooks really want to
go black star square bishop is a thorn
in white side and the only way to get
rid of it is to trade off yeah instead
of bishops
no more bishop a bishop against the
knight alone you can't control both
colour complexes i think this last game
is probably affected duda um the fact
that magnus went one f3 it might be a
very clever i kind of call it a gangster
move you know it's kind of like you know
it's kind of a rude but like
psychological move you're playing a
match you play this move you get you get
into your opponent's mind and they're
thinking why can't i beat one f3 and you
saw him dude at the end he didn't want
to do the interview wanted to go
straight to his room and it might it
might just been a very clever it's a
match after all a very clever ploy to
put him off you know big psychological
blow if your opponent plays a move like
that an opening like that and you can't
win
uh that'd be okay that being said wow
what is magnus doing um maybe a good
move
but a surprising one he's just trying to
bring his king to the c7 square he's not
castling but he's doing what we call
castling by hand he's just moving his
king across the board and he can do that
because it's an end game there aren't
that many open lines for the opponent
white now bringing his rook across he
does want to push the pawn forward one
square so i'm expecting magnus to maybe
try and stop that but
yeah um it feels like magnus he's just
kind of freestyling he's just uh doing
what he wants because he's very
comfortable in end games
in this type of position and the reason
as well i should just explain
strategically why i don't like what dude
has done on this left side of the
borders if you've got a light squared
bishop and your opponent doesn't put
your pawns on the opposite colour your
bishop will do its own work on the light
squares put pawns on dart squares and
okay he's finally put a pawn on a dart
square duda but shaking his head that's
because magnus is gaining all the space
now on the queen side throwing pawns you
could clearly see can't you david from
the look on his face look at it he's not
happy at all i mean i think magnus has
got into his mind yeah i think it's as
simple as that i mean like that is not a
happy doodah happy dude
[Laughter]
looks like logically
not broken but yeah busted at the very
minimum yeah yeah yeah but this is the
beauty of the fact that we're actually
watching him play live yeah yeah on the
esports arena i can't turn the camera
off yeah he can't we can see actually
see how he's uh suffering and how he has
to kind of dig deep
use grit and try to recover because this
is not the ideal start to to this uh
game especially with the white pieces he
hasn't got what he wants magnus has done
everything right look at him magnus is
just taking all the space on the left
side of the board it's his favorite
thing in the world
and uh
madness's position is just awesome
actually yeah so i think black's just
better here isn't it i mean
with some chances to open up the a file
uh the black knight can now be a very
nice piece coming in there's a lot of
holes in the position uh you can see
where the black bishop is that's a real
square under magnus's control now so
it's uh
it's magnus will be happy the way this
has gone definitely it's a very constant
type of position just a stable end game
everything protected where he can easily
improve easy plans it's not a duda type
of position there are no real imbalances
no real attacking chances no real
creativity here
i think objectively he needs to just
retreat his bishop white's bishop on the
edge of the board retreat back one
square trade off bishops and then just
try and lock things down try and survive
for a draw i think duda needs to just
save this game move on to the next one
maybe hope that magnus plays f3 or move
one again but uh i think if duder just
if he's on tilt as we say and just
emotionally can't recover he'll bring
his bishop back two squares and
he's not looking happy no i think he
can't play for the win in this game
anymore he just needs to go on the
defensive and try and survive and bring
it to game four okay he's doing that now
yeah i mean one thing i've noticed a lot
of the top players very good at even if
they're very depressed and he's not
happy is he
they're very good at like shutting up
the shop you know they they realize like
you know if i keep going
i'm gonna lose i have to change gear
and i think other players you know like
myself i'm very bad at changing gear
when i need to if the tide's going
against me i will still keep pushing
which is just a big mistake i need to
like you know suddenly defend and these
players can do that very well but you're
still playing magnus you might be a bit
worse so it's not fun and that's the
thing sometimes the only way to shut up
the shop is to go passive to go
defensive and it's nobody's instinct
especially against the world champion
going passive it's no guarantee of a
draw uh playing for a draw is sometimes
the worst way to get that result
yeah but yeah it's just what he needs to
do he needed to get rid of black's
really strong bishop there
and uh still a lot of work for carlson
if he wants to win this game so it's uh
dramatic for young christoph duda if
magnus wins this game it's over he will
be the winner of the match the situation
is the same between jude and fun forest
and pragnanda if prague up by one point
wins
this game and he will be the winner of
that match but look at the bar all the
way over to jordan fanford's side
maybe he is about to make a comeback to
uh
tie that match after three games we'll
keep a close eye on that mamadiarov is
up by one point and his match against
liam leia game three has started and ish
geary and eric hansen they have played
two draws so far they are tied the bar
slightly maybe over to anish's side in
game three we'll of course keep an eye
on that as well
but it's looking very good for magnus
carlsen a draw in this game with the
black pieces is a great result and he
only needs a draw in in game four in
that case yeah with the white pieces i
think magnus if he only needs a draw
he'll play something a bit more solid
than we saw him play in that last game
like any move
any other move on f3 i mean that was one
of the most classic interviews i've ever
seen in chess just saying you wanted to
play f3 to switch things up yeah he had
some ideas yes
well for him for him yeah um yeah
and uh okay uh as expected duder has to
fight for the dark squares he's only got
a light squared bishop now so he does
put a pawn on a dart square that white
rook on the second rank wants to switch
over to look at the white uh look at the
black king i i thought magnus might have
prepared some night night move that's
why he put his rook down on the last
room to stop this idea but i don't know
if the black knight can come forwards
now uh that that's the first thing you
look at here some tactic with it and
okay it hasn't gone for the more solid
option it's gone to a safe square simon
you were mentioning it can jump to maybe
this square or this square uh just
attacking the white rook utilizing a
really nice tactic
if the pawn takes the knight now then
the white rock is actually undefended
and it would fall to the black rook so
uh using this pin it looks like uh
you're hitting this rook now but i think
the white rock just moves and maybe this
pawn i think actually this this kind of
move like i've just you just demonstrate
david moving the knight there it's a
real uh common mistake that a lot of uh
lower rated players will play because
it's an artificial move yeah it looks
aggressive it looks like it does
something but you're not really seeing
far enough it just ruins your position
makes your position worse even though it
seems semi-aggressive it just backfires
and the move that magnus played much
more classy got long-term idea of
bringing that into the center that's
right one move tricks are nice sometimes
especially in speeches but i mean this
is the top level you can't just hope
that your opponent will fall for your
idea and yeah as you mentioned often
just putting pieces on good squares is
the uh the wiser option until you feel
it's the right moment until your
opponent's off balance and then you can
go for those types of tricks but this
knight's just on a good square and if we
do see for example pawn takes pawn then
suddenly this pawn is a backward one
it's eyed up by the black rook it's
never gonna move really and uh yes white
can create some threat for example
against this pawn in front of the black
king but at the very very minimum black
can just block the diagonal of the white
bishop and that's why again that was a
great square for the knight a great
route into the center of the board and
even if we see a trade here it's only
black who can ever be better because
white has an isolated pawn a backwood
pawn and black's king is nearer the
action nearer the center
so magnus still
pretty confident i'm not sure he's going
to win this game but a draw as uh kai
mentioned is a decent result for black
anyway
and he looks ready to get that one at
the very least absolutely yeah magnus
will be very very happy here i mean to
me it's like a dream position for a
caracal player you know we thrive on
those
small little details
um despite all this i'm actually a big
picture person
i never never liked little details this
is why i was not very good at law
because it was all about those fine
little moments those fine wordings and i
was like oh i just wanted to get it done
but as a cara player i'm used to those
small little things that kind of
eventually become bigger advantages yeah
i actually thought that and the clocks
and started because i looked at magnus's
time and i thought oh 15 minutes the
clocks are wrong
but he just hasn't spent any time so
it's like
which is quite quite strange right um
you know he's playing very natural very
quick and as i think david mentioned
he's this is his element position where
he's got a slight slight advantage easy
moves to play put the pieces on the best
squares
yeah and uh i think it's just because
it's his type of position we talk about
style a lot but if you're in a position
that you recognize the pawn structures
if you have a lot of experience you can
just
pure instinct and you barely need to
pause to think and zero calculation in
this game so far have you ever been in
this position david or move whatever it
is be like on the same time you started
on you knew the answer to that one i
don't yeah yeah i've never had more time
i'm sure david had more time than his
money started when he played against me
i i i made a mess of the whole thing
but uh okay well whilst we're waiting
for the players to make a decision i do
want to share with you a selfie from
nancy who says even an asthma attack
can't stop me watching from the
beautiful colorado rocky mountains
and uh yeah that sounds quite
quite uh
dramatic yeah worrisome and nancy said
do look after yourself and we do hope
that you can provide some entertainment
at the same time
and big hello and if you do want to send
your selfies or your questions or tell
us who you're cheering for and whether
you're enjoying watching magnus play
some fine chess or dig some music
yeah then do tweet us using the hashtag
chess champs
definitely
and uh i wish i knew the songs we have
to we have to get that feature in to
actually be able to see the song they're
listening to all the players what kind
of music does matt you said you made
made him a music list what kind of music
do you think magnus will be listening to
yeah i i don't i can't take credit for
making the music list that goes to us
skill oh it's kind of surprising but uh
yeah it was the songs that i was kind of
dropping into the commentary the song
titles at least that was dropping into
the commentary last season one night in
bangkok which you would
i was just a little trick all right oh
nice yeah yeah and you got in like what
40 songs or something like that that's
really impressive actually
and i mean magnus it depends on his mood
i i mean i don't think he's as much a
fan as techno as eric hansen uh the
chess bro but uh yeah techno on occasion
some rock some pop
and okay dude meanwhile after a long
long think
sliding his rook across similar i did
idea to the one we pointed out he's
trying to line up against the black king
but uh okay black just solidifies
everything that black rook now defends a
couple of pawns next to it
slightly surprised we didn't see the
black knight jump into the center but uh
okay this one's pretty solid as well
from carlson
he does really like those 90s uh hits
right yeah he's very good at music
quizzes and
when we do karaoke it's not just he
knows the songs it's the fact that
he always knows a kind of
fun kind of piece of trivia about the
song about
who wrote it or about the year it was
published uh year it was released and uh
yeah it's just crazy memory impressive
yeah
i wonder what kind of music young
christopher judah would listen to what
what should he listen to right now he
needs to get fired up and all right if
this is a draw to find a way to win the
next game what music would be good to
listen to i don't know whether it's an
advantage to listen to music and you
know obviously magnus likes it he enjoys
it he thrives on it eric hanson's
another one but
for most of us who are not used to
playing chass with noise i mean it can
be a bit distracting especially if you
have one of these cheesy songs in your
head the last thing you need is like
something
i don't know
some kind of poppy yeah disco thing how
about classical music yeah i like
classical music i mean i i definitely i
like i listen to music movie music like
sometimes like han zimmer
you know something like that in the
background and you feel like yes
i'm going to play this move up most of
drama this is my moment yeah that's what
i would listen to as well yeah oh yes do
you play the moves like you know like
like like
like could do the show oh yes
i'll move the mouse maybe you have to
move the mouse which you can't quite do
right now well you could do you could do
a nice grand gesture
conductor
this conductor
uh okay one move by duda doesn't change
anything magnus just thinking now
is he gonna plonk his knight into the
center of the board just shut things
down could he sort of start playing on
dude's clock so
you know it sounds like on you guys that
this is very drawish disposition but the
fact that young christopher has a lot
less time on his clock yeah
and uh drawish maybe but it's kind of
minimum drawish for black okay i think
white is the one fighting for the draw
and okay very clever move therefore by
duda however uh black's rooks lining up
on white central pawn and white's rook
now stepping up to hit black's pawn on
the side of the board i was going to say
it's not just the clock times but magnus
despite the fact they're kind of playing
on computer screens he could just kind
of take a peek over at duda to check out
the body language duda shaking his head
will have been noticeable surely
so there's still that kind of element of
reading the opponent and
magnus he knows the style of all of
these players in the uh in this
tournament but he also he is very good
at reading body language he became
number one in the world basically by
grinding people down tiring them out and
so he played poker recently he's a
player poker competition which he loves
people he he reads people so well so
yeah yeah he shouldn't mention that over
at duda then he'll know he's in charge
yeah magnus participated in the
norwegian poker
championship but only what like a week
or two ago yeah and he did really well
yeah is he an expert on poker i mean i
think he's very good
and i hear also the reporter as european
champion as well so yeah yeah
our reporter out in the lounge he's an
amazing poker player
and well apparently he's always magnus
he i think he ended up in 25th place
25th and i think a thousand odd players
started
and yeah i mean some of the hands he was
bluffing with
he meets people better than anyone and
yeah some impressive players as well um
yeah hopefully he doesn't switch to
poker full-time but he definitely could
if he wanted to what was a multi-talent
right chess obviously fantasy premier
league we also have to sort of analyze a
lot and poker apparently and sports as
well he's very good at sports
and okay at least the game now the
position is starting to take shape the
black knight kicked away from the center
attacked by this pawn i'm expecting it
to jump into white's half into the white
position to the c3 square but then the
white rook on the fifth rank can come
across and grab
is alice or anna the a pawn alice alice
in wonderland harry
pointed all right
it's gonna go across and grab a pawn uh
the black rooks in the center on the d
file will grab the d-pawn but uh it will
just be a trade and to be honest i feel
that helps white somehow instinctively
then again the black piece is very very
active very centralized and well
coordinated as well yeah
i think i mean
some of the weaknesses are going to be
removed from the board here which
probably favors white yeah
we'll lose weakness yeah and maybe
white's rook is going to get a little
bit active so it
may seem this move due to play bringing
the rook up into the center uh was a
very good way um to to well
maybe even equalize the position
somewhat doesn't mean it's going to be a
draw but equalizing i think yeah it
feels like maybe black had more accurate
ways to put pressure on or kind of
at least to kind of stabilize and kind
of prolong the tension in order to let
duda run low on the clock before taking
action it feels like magnus kind of
rushed things slightly and
uh duda looking less
uncomfortable less unhappy than he did
earlier okay magnus is about to push a
pawn to attack white's look in the
center of the board but that entails
risk and there we go he does push that
pawn to attack the white rook is the
white rook going to move that's the
question or can you even capture the
black knight we saw that in game one
today between these two magnus was the
one who actually gave up a rook for a
night
we could see do to do the same it's
tempting very tempting it's so tempting
capture the night and uh suddenly
the evaluation bar jumped meant that
maybe there was an opportunity is it
this one
the white rook now going for different
targets but the black knight very active
what do you think guys is white's rook
gonna capture harry the h pawn or is it
gonna capture alice the apron white's
rook has a choice in both uh how many i
mean i think magnus is taking some risks
right i mean he didn't need to play this
way
uh he still wants to win this game
clearly by doing this and he's offering
up uh well he's allowing the white rook
to become very active so it could
backfire possibly uh this one and if i
was white
i'd probably go for the h pawn i guess
so but it's not clear you just want a
harry of your own i just want to get rid
of that harry and then queen my harry
now one thing i should mention as well
knights are really bad at stopping flank
pawns later in the game so if for
example that white rook on the right
half of the board does go up and capture
a pawn then if it comes to a pawn race
if all the rooks disappear later black's
knight might not be so happy
uh yeah i'm just surprised as you said
magnus taking risks yeah yeah need to in
this
situation here's a point up in today's
match i would capture alice
yeah because you know it's actually not
possible to grab the center pawn because
there is a check along the seventh row
so you have to take some time out to
defend against that should we have a
vote guys simon thinks harry is going to
drop
alice do you think alice
because
he has to be frank kaya what are you
going to vote for is white going to
capture the h pawn or the 8th well simon
said that he really liked to get the h
pawns off the board to get that open
line so i'll vote for harry then yeah
that's the one we're going to harry and
thank you for alice too soon
okay who's going to be correct
who's is magnus's move so i guess no
it's dude
now right yeah under three minutes he's
going to make this
this decision do we
alice
it's yes
critical error there throwing the game
away do the losers now we'll retrace our
steps
okay magnus actually goes to attack that
one this is the movie i was worried
about i thought the white rook now might
might have a bad move right yeah it's a
terrible move you know
the right rook can actually just move
over
attacking harry again or you can go to
see
see pawn as well yeah he's going to get
a bit fresh there and play yeah yeah
which is probably quite okay he's gone
back he wants everything he wants he
wants the a pawn and the h pawn okay
maybe you'll be right now maybe that
pawn will drop too and all the pawns
falling and then we all win and then we
will win yeah every once in a while
[Laughter]
i like your simultaneous movements
i mean we're getting excited but the
players they're they're cold as ice
they're stony-faced uh they're just in
pure calculation mode so duda he's just
thinking okay i'm gonna grab as many
pawns as possible magnus is a pawn down
now so maybe he's gonna start trying to
infiltrate with his rooks the black
rooks can come down maybe give a check
first maybe they can trade off white's
defender this white rook on the second
rank and black can start going for
white's pawns on the left flank it's
it's become a race whoa he goes passive
instead yeah i mean defensive move he
could have gone all in there can he buy
it by doing what you said david but this
is a more maybe he's just trying to move
his king forwards first and improve a
little bit before
he's got this up his sleeve i guess the
the the black rook coming down
um i mean i again you mentioned white
white is now porn up but it's easier for
black to play i i think this position
i'm looking what you do is white here
black can move forwards and push a
little bit yeah one of black's rooks can
also go to the a file which has been
vacated now that black's pawn there
disappeared and you can go after white's
remaining aporn which is a backwood fawn
black's knight on a great outpost so
yeah maybe g5 as well maybe get rid of
one pair of rooks exactly because even
the ending you're pawn down maybe
it's going to be a very good ending yeah
if you can get rid of white active rook
and leave white with the passive rook
also white's bishop not really
participating right now then yeah it's
not going to be easy so
maybe white has an advantage objectively
at least according to the computer there
but
in practical terms it's not easy at all
and especially in your situation
under two minutes yeah under two minutes
you know um
i really do like black's position but
like you guys say you know what has to
do something dramatic and i'm i'm
thinking great when i doubt
push
push just push it i was just gonna say
that you know try to create a past porn
and uh the past porn the one that's
unchallenged that's harry and uh get the
motoring that's your compensation
race well i mean that pawn could be very
dangerous um in a lot of situations i
mean g the g pawn is tied down the one
next to the white rook so black loses
that pawn as well then could be a game
winner
disaster for carlson if the black g pawn
disappears so kind of changing my
evaluation here i'm kind of thinking
like well i don't really know actually
but i kind of think like white is
certainly doing okay as well here yeah
it feels like no worries here may be
easier for black to play but not that
much risk for white because white's
extra pawn even if it does fall it will
take yeah there we go the most obvious
move in the position bring his rook
across even if that white a pawn falls
black needs three or four moves to go
and
kind of make any progress from that and
white's bishop activating itself yeah
very nice move and uh you can also push
harry again uh if he wants to but he's
trying to get the bishop in the game
with his last move break down the
blockade uh the evaluation bar going a
little bit up and down there but i
wasn't a big fan of that move just
because i was a little bit obsessed with
the idea of trying to do something uh
push my pawns in a harmonious way on the
right side if i were playing white
this way
nothing and then we saw a pre-move by
duda we just zoomed in on dude's screen
he had captured that pawn uh beforehand
in anticipation of magnus taking that
pawn a safe pre-move was a safe pre-move
as we call it because that was the only
scenario where white's bishop would have
ended up on this g4 square
and black's rook just doing a defensive
job guarding two pawns what's dude gonna
do now is he gonna get your move i mean
i i would push the h pawn if i could on
the side of the board because you create
a threat you just want to push it you
know all the way up yeah the only risk
kind of with that move if you push the h
pawn one more square is that white's
rook actually lacks escape squares yeah
so you're kind of banking on the fact
you can continue pushing that white pawn
forward another option would be just
improve the white king but uh that feels
a bit slow okay he rotates
so um yeah this square wouldn't have
been available if you pushed your pawn
forward
so it may be a nice move because he's
trying to centralize there is another
weakness that black has
which the white bishop is pointing in
that pawn so why not gang up magnus gets
rid of that weakness look at this i mean
it's really intriguing strategically
both players have ideas but magnus he's
taking time out to stop his opponent's
ideas feels like dude is trying to
create magnus is saying no dude to try
something else magnus says no and it's
just about whether duda finally gets
kind of his bishop to an active square
or gets his rooks attacking pawns if
magnus can continue kind of
rebuffing all of duda's ideas then duda
will get frustrated
and one minute now duda needs to somehow
improve his king somehow coordinate his
two rooks white's rooks are so far apart
from each other yeah and all the while
handling black's kind of play on the
left side you know black is going to
play knight takes pawn and then
go for the week
b porn yeah maybe even rook takes her as
if you can get rid of the rooks the
knight can come and yeah as dave said
goes for go for all those pawns on the
queen side
um
yeah i definitely prefer black and now i
feel but still upon down temporarily but
easier to play for black and that's what
that's why carlson is so good not just a
classical chess but also rapid blitz
because he finds positions that
objectively they might be a draw but
it's so much easier for him to find a
plan black's plan is simple grab a pawn
bring the black king in
and uh
holy cow 30 seconds now that's
incredible
dude are not confident we saw that early
on in the game he was already shaking
his head after the opening
and uh yeah if you don't like your
position if it's not your style that's
uh
that's an uphill struggle 10 seconds now
for dude yeah okay he just shuffles his
rope what do you think right now do you
think magnus will win this game yeah
obviously looking at the clocks as well
i think he's going to win this one yeah
um i just because it's his ideal
position and the time time situation so
the trend is all in black's favor
black's just grabbed upon back it's
level material and as you vanco
mentioned the next target is easy it's
the b3 pawn and
and duda is going to be desperate as
well and when you're desperate you don't
objectively play the best moves you
maybe kind of go passive when you should
go active you don't have time to
calculate to the best of your abilities
so yeah the heat is on for duda okay he
moves his king he is um
[Laughter]
could be quite a good one to play where
you're putting a bit of a pressure on
your opponent yeah or under pressure i
know yeah black knight is jumping in
attacking upon white bishop has had to
go passive and it's now time for the
black king to improve itself using every
piece carson
it's uh so impressive and how is white
going to stop this infiltration of the
black king the black king is just going
to use the the dark squares it's going
to zigzag its way in towards those white
pawns and there's only one move to kind
of do anything about it and i just
thought go active
create chaos on the board but he doesn't
he instead just moves his king up
[Laughter]
and there it is
here it comes active kings and end games
centralized kings that's all we talk
about but it's for a reason and now this
is a check black can answer it by
continuing to advance his king into the
position or we can even block this check
with a pawn
both look good to be honest it looks
horrible yeah yeah i mean i would be
tempted to block it with a pawn yeah
just to kind of keep that king move it's
the coordination the coordination of
black pieces is so impressive the knight
the king the pawn all centralized all
about hit weaknesses i mean i i think
this could be this could be the end my
only friend the end
you know
do you know the song grayson
no the doors oh okay this is the end
and i think we could see a result in a
few moves if magnus is accurate here
this last move is desperation from duda
he's trying to undermine black's central
pawn he's using a pin on the fourth rank
but
again the black king could even step in
the black knight can retreat if it needs
to
uh just to defend black's pawn in the
middle of the board
black's rook okay what is magnus going
to play he's hovering over his king with
his mouse he's going to bring his king
in he's going to bring the king in yeah
i mean also i have to say magnus has all
the time in the world he's got 10
minutes yeah
duda has only 30 seconds what's the
technique
do you keep your opponent hanging well
i've done this i mean again i i always
bring up my losses against david because
they're so traumatic there's so many of
them but i remember when you know
i i think you have to slow down i mean
personally if you've got a better
position then why why risk it you know
but you can hustle a bit i think if your
position's bad then you then you go
quicker but it depends on the situation
here magnus doing well there's no reason
to to rush
uh saying that i think he's seen a good
plan and he's just playing it
so
now there is some calculation to be done
however because after this check white's
king is going to move i'm not sure where
if we see a trade of rooks uh in the
center of the board then we do have to
calculate is black's knight able to go
and grab a pawn on the b3 square or is
white's central pawn going to start
running up the board so trade of rooks
or no trader brooks magnus has to work
this one out really carefully i mean i
guess just sliding the rook to the left
here looks
very sensible way to play uh keep it
active and because trading rooks is
either very good or it's very bad so
that's the first thing you should look
for i guess captures uh threats checks
but if it doesn't work then yeah as you
mentioned simon look for alternatives
bring the rook across either to the
center or even the whole way uh you're
right it's actually a moment where he's
got the time so you might as well work
out if rook takes work works it wins so
why not spend a minute or two just
working it out it'd be you know um and
you can just
count basically there can't you wish
porn's going to queen first and also if
you don't have too much time i mean just
be practical you know rook takes work
involves a lot of risk you have to be
precise if you just slide your rook
you're still in control of field play
and uh
again why hasn't it passed pawns okay
just to show yeah he does indeed slide
his rook across uh the alternative would
have been rook tate's rook and knight
takes pawn but then you do have to
calculate a little bit about whether
this pawn is quick enough so uh he did
choose the safe option the rook slid
across and now duda desperation again he
doesn't give a check which uh maybe we
would have expected partly because the
black king can just move
maybe even the black rook blocks instead
he pushed his pawn forward and
there's just one drunk uh one trap one
trick in the position knight takes pawn
actually loses a piece i think after a
rook check and suddenly this is a skewer
and the knight drops off to the white
bishop or white rook next move so only
one trap in the position maybe there's
another trap if you check and then take
the other pawn uh
then dude has got this potential uh
fork yep that's the world attack check
and uh hitting the knight hitting the
king so actually two traps maybe and uh
magnus magnus just needs to avoid those
uh so he could do that maybe by bringing
his rook in offering a trade
at least dude is fighting he's fighting
hard
yes dramatic for him if he loses this
it's gonna be over minus will be the
winner of the match gaining three points
and uh seven thousand five hundred
dollars it's going to be zero points for
duda if it's not able to get at least a
draw in this game and the situation is
actually the same between
jordan from forest and the youngest
player in the tournament pragnanda the
bar all the way over to his side and the
16 year old could be about to decide
this after
three games you said it at the start of
the day david
pragnanda is one of the players to look
out for yeah i mean he's only 16 but
he's rising so fast i mean he's
accelerating
due to covet he wasn't able to show how
much he's been improving week by week
and he's on a hot streak as well winning
tournaments with someone said in
reykjavik and um again difficult opening
for pregnant but he's turned it around
he's a fighter and uh he calculates so
well no weaknesses in his game and he's
on the brink of winning this match does
knight b2 just win here by the way
potentially um just just seeing this
night jump that magnus might be able to
play and i'm not sure how white
saves his bishop of that and that lucky
square there's so many great players i
mean young players it's so hard to
predict
which of them will potentially become a
world champion
yeah oh yeah yeah
does it work out do i really check mate
myself
yeah i just i just spotted that as well
it's not a very good move is it actually
so nice
it does allow a big check but uh yeah
that's a good point i was missing no no
it's actually on the board
yeah because you can't because the
knight covers the critical square right
so it's okay my heart jumped a little
bit yeah yeah when i realized that
possibility but okay it's all good i
think the only way to save the game is
for the white rook to drop back one
square give a check to the king and then
you can swap the rooks off right that's
the winning idea okay yeah i think if
the rooks disappear yes white's a pawn
up but actually it's more important that
black is about to capture all of white's
pawns on that left side of the board and
10 seconds for duda he's got to give a
check it's forced and as mentioned a
rook trade is inevitable if white runs
away the white bishop drops to the black
knight so a rook trade and it's not just
the fact that white's pawns are dropping
white bishop as well terrible piece no
squares
and
okay you have to bank everything now on
your pawns knights are pretty bad at
stopping these corner pawns as i
mentioned earlier but at the very least
again blacks and i can go and capture
some of them you can step back with a
check you can go and capture another
pawn is it worth going on a detour and
actually grabbing
harry giving a check grab harry come
back
and complete the mission tempting yeah
white king might get active maybe you
can even calculation maybe even
centralize your king first just to stop
the white white king coming forwards and
then you can go and do that plan that's
sadistic excitement
you've got to be in the ending haven't
you you've got to be uh yeah and look at
that pragnanda it's a win in game three
and that means he is the winner of that
match against jordan from force after
only three games winning
two games pragnando the first player to
gain three points in the oslo esports
cup that is
so impressive as magnus
shakes his head
is he frustrated about something i think
he's just trying to calculate that i
mean i i don't think there's anything to
be frustrated about here
in the position he's got i mean it's
these positions a lot of it is just
number crunching you've just got to work
out variations and you can go quite deep
um and the first thing he's trying to
calculate here is if he can go knight
takes pawn david might even better show
it on the board uh potentially when you
have just a race situation
and they're quite bit i always recommend
for people who are trying to learn that
endings
are very good tactical endings um
because they really help your tactical
play because there's only one variation
you need to try and visualize and uh you
can go down it extremely deeply
but okay has he played a move here david
yeah he's played a different move he
didn't go after these pawns maybe
because as you mentioned simon we would
see a bit of a race the pawns could step
forward and to be honest i think this
looks very good for magnus he could have
stepped back and blockaded the white
pawns advance but instead he went for a
different option he went for the one you
mentioned earlier uh just getting rid of
harry dropping back with the check and
after the king moves i think he's about
to take this pawn just to remove it off
the board removal risk but you do allow
the white king to be active uh this
white king now slightly better placed
maybe you could step forward with this
pawn and try to activate this bishop now
you're hitting the knight maybe next
move you can try and start bringing it
to hit some other targets
but
yeah magnus he's the only one playing
for the win dude fighting for the draw
with 10 seconds it's still not easy to
defend this position i'm expecting to
push the pawn because what else simply
but uh not so easy for magnus anymore
can you go king e4 i'm just running
which is basically yeah i think as well
that's another option and it's on the
board and uh 17 seconds left but dude
not a lot of time oh dramatic for him
and look at the bar in this game and
then they're going to have a game
between anish geary and eric hanson the
bar jumping up for eric hanson the
lowest rated player in the tournament
could be about to make a huge hop sense
against geary bunch of moves in this one
bunch of moves and this one still looks
very very good now for black and uh the
reason i didn't mention that king
advanced earlier is because white bishop
actually got trapped which of course did
by the black king which of course i
didn't see
completely missed
i mean i think the position was very bad
wasn't it it's very bad yeah you know
just maybe with best player you could
have found some tricks or some way to
save it but uh not easy and magnus now
it's a pawn race both sides have pawns
on this left side of the board but the
black knight the key is it can drop back
to help and there we go it's going to
try and sacrifice itself for white sea
pawn and then black's b-pawn is going to
promote and win the game black is going
to end up with a new queen
and look at the evaluation bar plus
nearly plus 16. yeah
yes yeah the big problem also is that
the black king can take a step backwards
and also cover some squares as well